John joins us now would you think of the
3430 John well it's true got a lot of
attention sir got a lot of downloads I
might hit it hard song that was pretty
cool Danny and you're in the top 100 now
with that song aren't you yeah went to
88 and went back up to 91 I don't know
what it's doing today but that's that's
just awesome what what part of was love
the 30 for 30 was the toughest to talk
about or here again I I think it's you
know what Thomas Henderson I mean you
know the greatest thing that ever
happened to me is I when you're down and
you're low and nothing's going right you
actually I can actually say I had two of
the most wonderful friends that pretty
pretty much saved my life from from that
that night and that was Thomas Henderson
and Donnie Crabtree I mean there's no
doubt but you're on the you were gonna
kill yourself yeah it's in the Mercedes
on a cliff up around Palm Springs going
to sort the mountainside towards San
Diego on the back there 78 I guess is
the road I'm not sure what the roller
can't remember it but right on a cliff
and you reach out to Thomas Hollywood
Henderson who was a friend of yours you
met in rehab back in the early 90s and
then he talked you how to kill in
yourself yep my buddy Donny back in that
day how did you get to that point when
you look back the golf game was bad me
and Paul that were going through the
divorce
you know I was getting ready to check
myself back into the Betty Ford I had
that ordeal and Sawgrass I mean loss
Wilson loss Reebok lost every sponsor I
had lost it all how did the documentary
treat that I liked they did a wonderful
job they didn't they they went into it
like right into it they didn't beat
around the bush on it or anything and
that's kind of what I loved about David
and Gabe the guys who did the show it
was just spot-on we just did it and you
know I wish the show had a little bit
more of my Boys and Girls Club and the
make-a-wish stuff but I did and showed a
little bit more of you know maybe my
family a little bit more would have been
nice but you know I think
the cool thing about advantage is I just
it's cool that that I could actually
tell a story that hopefully might help
somebody you know it might know that
until the world that hey all athletes if
you consider golfer athlete which I
think most people do I mean that we do
go through troubles and we go through
some bad times and in that you know we
need help just we need help in this
we're we're not I'm not scared to reach
out and get help is what I'm trying to
say and and I think it's just part of
life and there's so many people that go
through it we all have our ups and downs
did you have depression when did you
know that you had that gene in you that
you could be depressed that you know
self-destructive gene maybe I think we
all have it in it just a matter if we do
it or not you know I think everybody
gets to trust every now and then you
know and that life's not supposed to be
just perfect nobody's perfect and I
think like I said I think as long as you
got good people around you we can get
through it when did you know it was was
alcohol problem when you actually played
no no I wasn't the problem I played if I
played bad it when I got drunk sometimes
I play good I when I've got drunk I mean
you didn't drink on the course no just
that one time in LA
the LA open huh you know we played the
back nine I was three or four over par
and went in and down four or five chords
lights and shot four hundred on the on
the front and ended up finishing like in
the top ten that week I didn't think I
was gonna make the cut did you ever
think about drinking you know sometimes
you'll find somebody who says why I can
have a drink alright gonna have to drink
say you know I I I got this under
control
did you have that you go through those
moments well back in the nineties I
really didn't have it under control that
was the sad part about it I just when I
got to feelin really good it just seemed
like I wanted to drink more so I could
feel bad I don't I don't I really it
sort of explained but now when I drink I
get a nice little buzz I don't I just
stop I'll just start drinking diet cokes
talking to John Daly the 34:30 there's a
lot of stuff in there you know you
talked about gambling
was there enough good stuff in there
John I guess you know cuz I I think that
when we think people are gonna eat up
the negative you know it's not like
they're gonna man I did you see the
story about John Daly and it was
something positive it feels like that we
love to focus on the negative was it
fair to you you think all around
I just wish like I said I would sit with
a soda more of the good side you know of
me I do have a good side I just want
people to know that it's in there I've
seen a John I've seen it you know I mean
they talked about the 91 95 British Open
but you know it perceived as the media
is this a one and done guy but you know
92 I when the BC open beat one of the
best golfers in the world Evers Phil
Mickelson beat him by six shots in 92 94
won the BellSouth classic and then 95 I
wasn't playing really good that year and
I just loved st. Andrews and you know
that four year span I want four golf
tournaments you know and it wasn't like
I was forgotten Sol but you know the 90
after 95 it was tough I didn't win
anything until 2004 and it just I wish
it would have showed a little bit more
of the family side and and my charity
work because you know I I don't ever
have me to use it my charity events but
if you're going to do a story like that
it's been nice to post how much I've
raised for Boys and Girls Club and how
much I did for make-a-wish when I lived
in Memphis for 19 years and that's the
only thing I wish it would have showed a
little bit more else at your peak you
versus Phil versus tiger and it's just
you three no cameras 18 holes what
happens if we're all playing the best of
our abilities yeah oh my god it'd be fun
it Behe be hard to say it would do it
went but at your best do you think you
were as good as tiger no not putting
wise I think ball striking wise I might
I might have been to look about the same
but putting tiger's putter is probably
the best 10 years I've ever seen putting
in my life what about film you equal toe
to toe with Phil me and Phil we've had
we've had some good matches you know I
meet him at the BellSouth I mean at the
BC open in 92 and and we played a few
times he's beaten me I'm beating him
but me and Phil are kind of kind of like
I mean we have our game is all feel you
know I think Tigers was more he was more
game management he has a little bit of
mechanics in his golf swing but me and
Phil were more like just field players
what do you want 10 years from now when
I talk to you what are you doing
hopefully watching little John play golf
do you want him to play going I love I
want him to do whatever he wants and
right now he loves the game of golf and
that's what he wants to do and I'm gonna
support him I'm not one of these dads
that pressure him to do it I don't coach
him unless he asked me and I just let
him kind of do his own thing because
he's also got that natural ability in
great hands he can chip and putt better
than I can right now
he doesn't have a mullet though does he
like you did no no he's got beautiful
hair it is just a beautiful kid fall in
love during a round of golf
fall in love yeah with somebody you know
in the gallery all probably 50 60 how do
you how do you go about playing golf
while you're trying to flirt with
somebody in the gallery well once you
get their phone number that's that's the
cool thing back then you just get the
phone number then you call them to see
if they want to go out how do you get
the number ok the caddies not gonna do
it for you I'm from Arkansas buddy
there's a line if there's a line in the
3430 that you saw yourself too ugly for
women to be naturally drawn to you but
then you said you love pleasing them so
that sort of was what you were all about
with women that's pretty much yeah but
you got a great woman now I do I have
great people in my lives my kids are
healthy life couldn't be any better dan
I just wish the game would come around a
little bit get the putter going and I'm
looking forward to next year and I'm
also looking forward the December 9th
10th and 11th the pnz it's a Champions
Tour event where I get to play with
Little John there no nice nice so
we're looking forward to that he's all
excited he goes dad do I get the money I
said no but it's gonna go towards your
school that's costing 86 thousand a year
what happened I think I talked to you
that you want a tournament was it in San
Diego and then you spent it you spent it
all
then you tuned it like you went to Vegas
right after you wanted is that right no
when Tiger beat me when I finished
second he'll kill mad in the playoff
like I said you know what I don't
deserve this 7-iron 20 grand I'm going
to Vegas and I just blew it all did you
ever bet on sporting events
no no that's not something I do
did you ever bet on you when you went to
the British Open no no no I guess that's
good that you didn't bet on sporting
events
it was just what craps are slot machines
a lot of my was blackjack I lost all my
millions on blackjack I quit playing
that game probably eight nine ten years
ago I just play slots for fun now I
finally realized going into a casino I
don't I'm not worried about if I want to
lose any more because I'm not playing as
much as I used to and I play with what I
can afford and I go in to relax and have
a good time in the 90s I went in
thinking I'm gonna break the house but
I've been with guys and they look
miserable as they're betting twenty
twenty-five thousand dollars a hand
couldn't couldn't you just feed your
gambling addiction but not have so much
money attached to it
it's all about the adrenaline yeah you
know two hundred forty thousand sitting
in front of you so you could play seven
hands you know got fifteen twenty thirty
thousand a hand I mean you know 210
grand on on one hand seven ways you're
gonna get your blood flowing oh my god
now they only let you play three three
boxes
that's good thing yeah did you ever have
a bad beat where you just went like this
like every gambler has a bad beat do you
have one oh my god the Hilton one year
in Vegas I lost five hundred
seventy-five thousand dollars in one
shoe no boy six decks - what'd you do -
after that I think I went out and got
this I think I just went back and got
absolutely ham
nice well don't check I'm glad you've
changed but don't change now John no I'm
still the same old John I just do
everything in moderation now got a
boring
I got a boring man that's great man hey
I hope to see at Augusta next year and
enjoyed meeting your lady down there of
this past April overslept
not a key time I've done that too what's
that feeling like when you miss your tee
time
oh you're embarrassed more than anything
that's about it you just you're
embarrassed I mean it's happens happens
all of this Jim fear cap to him last
year you know it just happens sometimes
well I hope you enjoyed the 34:30 and
hopefully I'll see you see you soon down
in Augusta you got buddy thank you John
work Danny I love you bub
thank you John the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience